WAI CHEE DIMOCK: So let me just
start with Faulkner.
This is a really interesting
image of Faulkner in Japan.
We know that Faulker so much
associated with Oxford,
Mississippi.
But he actually traveled quite a
bit under the sponsorship of
the State Department.
He was there because the State
Department asked him to travel
around and to give talks.
And what's interesting about
Faulkner in Japan is that some
of the most interesting things
that he says about his own
novels were actually said when
he was in Japan, in the course
of the Nagona seminar, 1955.
And this is really what
he says about The
Sound and the Fury.
"This is how the book grew.
That is, I wrote the same
story four times.
None of them were right, but I
had anguished so much that I
could not throw any of it away
and start over, so I printed
it in the four sections."
I mean this is obviously
tongue in cheek.
He's saying that he's written
so much in four different
ways, that he can't bear to
get rid of any of it.
So he's keeping all four, and
it's the same story told four
times, tongue in cheek.
But there's an element
of truth in it.
So let's try out, follow Faulker
in that thought.
And think of The Sound and the
Fury, the four sections of The
Sound and the Fury as
theme and variation.
So it's a very interesting,
musical
structure, theme and variation.
Basically it's really the same
story, but told from four
different point of view using
four different narrative
techniques.
And so producing different
effects, but really they are
all rooted in the same
phenomenon, which makes sense.
I mean it's really
the same story.
Another way to think
about this --
and this is really kind of
adding on to a sense that this
is theme and variation --
is the notion of kinship.
And this is really closer to our
thematic understanding of
the novel, that the three
brothers, each gets to tell
his story in one section, and
then the full section is told
by an omniscient narrator.
But the first three sections
are told by the
three Compson brothers.
So there is kinship
among them.
And we'll think about the
extent to which they are
brothers, they are kin, in both
a biological sense, but
perhaps also in more than
just a biological sense.
So let me just lay out the three
ways in which Benjy and
Quentin might be seen as kin.
And this is very much using the
three analytic registers
that we've been using
all the way through.
The three analytics scales --
the largest scale the shared
macro history.
This is commonsensical.
They live in the United States
after the Civil War.
So that is the common
ground between them.
And in fact, it doesn't
take brothers to
have that common ground.
And especially thinking about
race relations, and the
tomorrow of race, thinking back
to that line from Macbeth
Act V, Scene Five.
So that's the largest ground
for kinship between them.
And then there's another ground
for kinship, which has
to do, obviously, with
Faulkner's narrative
experimentation and the
traumatic loss of Caddy that
we saw last time.
That's being repeated in
the Quentin section.
Likewise, the incomplete syntax
that is so striking in
Benjy will also be repeated
in Quentin.
And finally, the importance of
the sense of smell that is in
Benjy will also be repeated
in Quentin.
We'll look at the kinship
first. And then
we'll look at variation.
Even though they're brothers,
they're different as well.
So basically today's lecture is
about kinship and variation.
But let's start with
the kinship.
And I want to talk a little bit
about race after the Civil
War, especially Faulkner's
understanding of that.
So in his 1956 interview with
the London Sunday Times,
Faulkner has this very
interesting thing to say.
"And the negro won't come out on
top, because of anything to
do with race, but because
he has always
gotten by without scope.
When they're given scope,
they use it fully.
They are trained to do more than
a white man can do with
the same limitations."
I have a little bit
of a cold, so.
This will be fine.
So this is the way that we like
to think about race, is
by going back to Macbeth,
Act V scene five.
And the first line actually of
Macbeth, Act V, Scene five,
is, "Tomorrow, and tomorrow,
and tomorrow." And thinking
that, mapping that onto
race relations.
We see that Benjy
is 33 years old.
What kind of a future
does he have?
And what kind of future do the
other black characters have?
So let's look at Benjy first.
And thinking about what
future, what tomorrow
holds for Benjy.
And this is very early on, the
opening of the Benjy section.
"Listen at you now,
Luster said.
Ain't you something.
33 years old, going
on that way.
After I done went all the way to
town to buy you that cake.
Hush up that moaning.
Ain't you going to help me find
that quarter so I can go
to the show tonight?"
Benjy can't talk, obviously.
So Luster is the one who is
doing all the talking.
But I think that Faulkner seems
almost to be emphasizing
that Luster is the player
in the present.
And he's going to be the
player in the future.
And everything that is being
done by Benjy, is being done
by Luster and Dilsey to some
extent, the two black
characters.
His mother isn't doing
anything for him.
Quentin is dead.
Caddy is gone.
So Luster is Beny's
only significant
other at this point.
And if for no other reason, the
future belongs Benjy, to
the extent that Benjy
could have a future.
That future can come
only from Luster.
So it's a really interesting way
to think about the future
as being race mediated
and race dependent.
Benjy is completely helpless.
Only Luster can give
him a future.
And Luster is doing that.
All the things that Caddy used
to do, Luster is doing.
He's telling Benjy to hush.
He's gone all the way to town
to buy a birthday cake for
Benjy because Benjy
is 33 that day.
And so in that sense,
he's a very good
significant other to Benjy.
But more than that, we see that
Luster actually has a
life apart from Benjy.
The last sentence of that
passage, "Ain't you going to
help me find that quarter so I
can go to the show tonight?"
Luster wants to go to
the show completely
independent of Benjy.
He has his own desires, he has
a life apart from Benjy.
And Benjy is really just an
aside, an appendage, and this
case, someone who should help
him to find that quarter, so
he can pay for the show
and go to the show.
So all this is to suggest that
the playing field has been
reconfigurated, and who is at
the center, who is the main
player, who is the protagonist
in this drama that is
unfolding into the future?
That really is an
open question.
And there's a strong suggestion
that the playing
field has been so re-constituted
that black
characters would be
the protagonist.
So let's think more about the
tomorrow of race, but going
off in a slightly different
direction.
This is the very end,
towards the very end
of the Benjy section.
So basically, we're looking at
the two moments that bracket
the Benjy section.
Once again, Benjy is with his
significant other, Luster.
"He put my gown on.
I hush.
And then Luster stopped, his
head toward the window.
Then he went to the window
and looked out.
He came back and took my arm.
Here she come, he said.
Be quiet now.
We went to the window
and looked out.
It came out of Quentin's
window and climbed
across into the tree.
We watched the tree shaking.
The shaking went down the
tree, then it came out.
And we watched it go
across the grass.
Then we couldn't see it.
Come on, Luster said.
There now.
Hear them horns.
You get in that bed where
my foot [? stays ?]."
OK, it's completely
ungrammatical
and that's just fine.
The future can belong to
people who don't speak
Standard English, it's
not a problem.
But what is interesting here
is that we are seeing
something that only one
person understands.
We are actually in exactly the
same position as Benjy.
We have no idea what's
going on.
The meaning of what they are
watching, whatever it is
that's coming out of Quentin's
window -- and this is the
female Quentin, the daughter
of Caddy --
whatever is happening,
whatever's coming out of
Quentin's window, what's going
to come after that, what
occasions that movement out of
that window, all of this will
not be disclosed to us until
section three, when we get to
the Jason section.
So there's a really interesting
differential of
knowledge in this moment.
Benjy obviously doesn't
know what's going on.
We, the readers, also don't
The only person who's fully in
command of the requisite
knowledge is Luster.
I think this is very
deliberately set up by
Faulkner to highlight the
extent to which black
characters have knowledge
and agency.
So much for Benjy, and obviously
Benjy is a part of
the black world.
I think that maybe we should
even suspend --
I mean, Benjy looks white.
He is pasty, actually.
But we can think of him as
really part and parcel of the
black world.
And his well-being is completely
dependent and, of a
piece with the well-being
of the black world.
But that is not the
case with Quentin.
Although Quentin also has very
important, nontrivial
relations to black characters.
And one black character who's
following him is the Deacon.
So this is a black man
in Massachusetts.
And this is what the Deacon
says to Quentin.
"Yes, suh.
Right dis way, young marster,
hyer we is,'
taking your bags ...
From then on until he had you
completely subjugated he was
always in and out of your
room, ubiquitous and
garrulous, though his manner
gradually moved northward as
his raiment improved, until at
last, when he had bled you
until you began to learn better
he was calling you
Quentin or whatever..."
So this is a black man who is
definitely not the same as the
Lusters and the Dilseys who have
stayed on in Mississippi.
This is a black man who
has moved north.
And here's important to have
some sense of the historical
background that Faulkner
is alluding to.
A black man going north, this
turns out to be one of the key
episodes in African-American
history, which
is the Great Migration.
In fact it happens
in several waves.
What we've seen here is the
first wave of Great Migration.
Roughly from 1910 to 1930, two
million African-Americans went
out of the south to the north,
to the midwest and the west.
And here is one image of the
Great Migration, the train
station almost completely
filled with blacks.
And here's a wonderful
painting by the
painter Jacob Lawrence.
If you are in DC, make sure to
go to the Phillips Collection.
It's a really interesting
collection.
It's just a private collection
of great paintings.
And they have the Jacob
Lawrence, The Great Migration
series, is almost 40
or 50 drawings.
So it's really a wonderful thing
that they have. And so
check this out when you're
in Washington, DC.
So as you can see, the people
are going to Chicago and New
York and St. Louis.
But some of them also end up
in Boston, Massachusetts.
And the Deacon ended up in
Boston, Massachusetts.
And once again, he starts out
sounding not only black, but
Southern black, calling
Quentin young master.
But then he actually, in the
course of one conversation, he
can actually metaphorically move
north, just in the space
of that one conversation.
So here is something else that
happens between Quentin and
the Deacon.
And this is actually very
obviously a backward allusion
to Macbeth, Act V, Scene five,
because the word tomorrow is
just repeated about eight times
in this little passage.
This is something that happens
that, when Quentin is thinking
about his future, and we
sort of know that he
has no future, right?
So this is someone with
no future talking to
someone with a future.
"Take this around to
my room tomorrow
and give it to Shreve.
He'll have something for you.
But not till tomorrow, mind.'
He took the letter and
examined it.
'It's sealed up.' 'Yes.
And it's written inside.
Not good until tomorrow,
mind.'...
He was looking at me now, the
envelope white in his black
hand, in the sun.
His eyes were soft and irisless
and brown, and
suddenly I saw Roskus watching
me from behind all his
whitefolks' claptrap of uniforms
and politics and
Harvard manner, different,
secret, inarticulate, and sad.
'You ain't playing a joke on the
old nigger, is you?' 'You
know I'm not.
Did any Southerner ever play a
joke on you?' 'You're right.
They're fine folks.
But you can't live with them.'
'Did you ever try?' I said.
But Roskus was gone.
Once more he was that self he
had long since taught himself
to wear in the world's
eye, pompous,
spurious, not quite gross.
'I'll confer to your wishes, my
boy.' 'Not until tomorrow,
remember."
So the letter is not going to
be delivered to Shreve until
Quentin is no more.
And the Deacon obviously will
still be there to reap the
benefit of delivering
that letter.
What is interesting here is the
very compressed time scale
that is packed into this
little exchange.
In the course of one
conversation, the Deacon can
slide back into someone just
like Roskus, still in
Mississippi from sometime back,
with the manner and the
diffidence and the
fear, really.
And lack of self-assurance from
some time past. He can
slip back into it.
But he's secure enough in
the present in Boston,
Massachusetts, that he can get
out of it, just also in the
space of one conversation.
So the Great Migration is not
just geographical migration,
but also psychological
migration as well.
That in his own mind, the Deacon
can move very, very
fast from the south
to the north.
And that agility of
movement is partly
what gives him a future.
And there's something else
about the slightly
ungrammatical and not quite
perfect command of English.
"I'll confer to your wishes." He
means to say, I'll defer to
your wishes.
But actually "confer" is the
more appropriate word.
Because he's not actually
deferring to Quentin anymore.
Deference is a thing of the
past, a thing of the
geographical south, and because
in Massachusetts, he's
actually conferring something.
It is up to him to be the agent
and to confer something
on Quentin.
So the re-composition of the
playing field is dramatized in
some sense through that
imperfect command of the
English language.
And so in this sense, Faulkner
is also rewriting both the
future of race, but also the
future of the history of the
United States.
So in both these ways, Benjy
and Quentin are really kin.
They have a lot in common in the
very facts, relations, to
black characters.
And another theory --
I think this is something that
you already know, but I just
wanted to refresh your memory,
they also are kin in the very
dramatic reaction to this loss
of innocence on Caddy's part.
So this is something that
we looked at last time.
Benjy, the moment when Caddy
can no longer go to the
bathroom and wash
herself clean.
"We were in the hall.
Caddy was still looking at me.
Her hand was against her
mouth, and I saw
her eyes and I cried.
We went up the stairs.
She stopped again, against the
wall, looking at me and I
cried and she went on and I
came on, crying, and she
shrank against the wall,
looking at me.
She opened the door to her room,
but I pulled her dress,
and we went into the bathroom
and she stood against the
door, looking at me.
Then she put her arm across her
face and I pushed at her,
crying."
So we remember this very well,
a moment when suddenly, Caddy
is not putting her arms
around Benjy, but
across her own face.
And it is telling that is almost
completely reproduced
and repeated in Quentin's
section.
"...one minute she was standing
in the door the next
minute he was pulling at her
dress and bellowing his voice
hammered back and forth between
the walls in waves and
she shrinking against the wall
getting smaller and smaller
with her white face her eyes
like thumbs dug into it until
he pushed her out of the room
his voice hammering back and
forth as though its own momentum
would not let it stop
as though there were no place
for it in silence bellowing."
It's exactly the same episode.
Except that now, all of a
sudden, we hear that sound,
that bellowing, that Benjy is
making, that of course is
invisible and inaudible when
Benjy is telling the story.
We know exactly what that
sound is doing.
Caddy seems to be shrunken.
She's getting smaller
and smaller.
She's so pushed around by Benjy,
that she's getting
smaller and smaller, until
she has no place to go.
And we really haven't thought of
Benjy as being aggressive.
But that's really what he is.
Innocence is aggressive in its
demand that the world should
completely conform
to his dictates.
And Benjy is relentless in
demanding that Caddy should
conform to his dictates.
And the bellowing is the weapon
that he uses to make
sure that she does that.
And when she cannot, he just
keeps on doing it.
So from Quentin, we have this
added perspective of what
Benjy is doing to Caddy.
But otherwise, it's exactly
the same moment.
The same Caddy, occupying
the emotional center.
And it's an unbearable place
for her two brothers to be.
It's not surprising then, that
the consequence of that
traumatic loss should be
articulated in the same way.
In Benjy, it's articulated as
incomplete syntax and the
consequences of that incomplete
syntax --
"I was trying to say, and I
caught her, trying to say, and
she screamed and I was trying to
say" -- and the frustration
would come after that.
Here's Quentin exhibiting the
same symptom, the same
reaction to the loss of Caddy.
And it is surprising, because
we can say that Benjy has an
incomplete syntax, because
he's an idiot.
He's clinically retarded.
Quentin is not retarded.
But, he also doesn't speak in
complete sentences when he's
very agitated.
"Because women so delicate so
mysterious Father said.
Delicate equilibrium of
periodical filth between two
moons balanced.
Moons he said full and
yellow as harvest
moons her hips thighs.
Outside outside of
them always but.
Yellow.
Feet soles with walking like.
Then know that some man that
all those mysterious and
imperious concealed.
With all that inside of them
shapes an outward suavity
waiting for a touch to.
Liquid putrefaction like drowned
things floating like
pale rubber flabbily filled
getting the odor of
honeysuckle all mixed up."
It really is stream
of consciousness.
It is completely internal
to Quentin.
And the logic of association is
also peculiar to Quentin.
So that it would be very hard
for us to understand
completely.
All we can say is that this is
both a point of commonality
between Quentin and Benjy.
And also the point of departure
or deviation.
From Benjy, we never get the
sense that women are filthy,
that there's something
really repulsive and
abominable about women.
That just having the menstrual
cycle, that in
itself is kind of filthy.
But this is really what Quentin
is fixated on, is this
kind of revulsion by female
sexuality in its most
elemental form.
In a sense that it doesn't
really take any action, just
in its state as femaleness,
there's something repulsive
about them.
So this is a way --
this stream of consciousness
--
is Faulkner's way of getting us
to get into a mind that is
very different.
In some sense, as different from
us as Benjy's mind is.
And so let's think about this,
also by way of the one thread
that Faulkner is giving us.
In the case of Benjy, we see
that the guide that is taking
us through the various salient
moments in Benjy, is the
phrase, "Caddy smelled
like trees."
And in the case of Quentin, the
phrase that will perform a
comparable function is,
"getting the odor of
honeysuckle all mixed up." We
see that, that's the last
sentence in that very
strange passage.
And that phrase will appear
again and again in the same
manner as Caddy smelled
like trees.
So let's use that as a way to
try to understand Quentin.
I don't think that we ever
will, completely.
And that probably is a good
thing, that's really the
effect that Faulkner
wants to cultivate.
And this is moving away from
kinship to thinking about
variation, the ways in
which Quentin is
different from Benjy.
And one way in which Quentin
is different from Benjy, is
that "sister" is basically
very, very clear, very
straightforward, uni-vocal
meaning for Benjy.
It only has one meaning.
Caddy smelled like trees.
She's the source of everything
that is wonderful and
comforting and good for Benjy.
The word sister has a much more
complicated meaning for Quentin.
So we can think of it instead of
just as one word, as a very
complex semantic field.
And what I'd like to do today is
to follow the trajectory of
that word sister, and the phrase
"honeysuckle all mixed
up." Follow that to try to get
us from the beginning of
Quentin's chapter, not quite as
linear as I would like, but
I'll try to get us from the
beginning of Quentin's section
to the end of Quentin's
section.
And I think we all know that
he kills himself, right?
He kills himself by
jumping into the
Charles River in Cambridge.
And so how does he get from--
and it's just one day, it's the
space of that one day--
how does he get from the
beginning of that day, that
morning, to the end
of that day?
And we'll begin at the
point when Quentin
is closest to Benjy.
And then the other ways in which
he gradually moves away
from Benjy.
But this is a moment when we
sort of know why it is, but
we're learning more about why
it is that Caddy's loss of
sexuality is so traumatic
to Quentin.
"Caddy you hate him don't you
She move my hand up against
her throat her heart was
hammering there poor Quentin
her face looked at the sky it
was low so low that all smells
and sounds of night seemed to
have been crowded down like
under a slack tent especially
the honeysuckle it had got
into my breathing it
was on her face
and throat like paint...
I had to pant to get any air at
all out of that thick grey
honeysuckle yes I hate him I
would die for him I've already
died for him I die for him over
and over again everytime
this goes when I lifted my
hand I could still feel
crisscrossed twigs and grass
burning into the palm poor
Quentin."
It's a weird moment.
Caddy is the one who is going to
be pregnant because of this
out of wedlock affair
with men --
with someone, actually,
she doesn't even know
who the father is.
So she is the last person to be
in a position to say, "Poor
Quentin." But Faulkner's
understanding of the situation
is that even though Caddy
is in a dire situation
at this moment --
and it's a much worse thing,
back in the 20s for a young
lady to be pregnant
out of wedlock --
But in spite of that dire
situation, Caddy still has a
better life than Quentin.
And it has to do with the
complete incomprehension of
Quentin for Caddy's life.
So in that sense too, we can say
this is the common ground
between Benjy and Quentin.
Benji doesn't understand Caddy
because he doesn't have the
mental capacity for it.
And Quentin doesn't understand
Caddy because he's never had
the experience, and we know by
the end of section two, that
he never will have
that experience.
What does it mean to have that
particular sensation, and to
have gone through that,
even though the
consequences are terrible.
So we can see another way in
which there's actually a point
of intersection between The
Sound and the Fury and The
Great Gatsby.
And there's really a lot in
common between Quentin and
Gatsby, as well.
The intense desire for the love
object to deny that she
has any relation to anyone
other than yourself.
This is what unites Quentin
and Gatsby.
Gatsby can't stand the thought
that Daisy might have been in
love with Tom at one point.
And Quentin can't stand the
thought that Caddy might
actually be in love, just at
that moment, when she's having
sex with this guy.
He can't stand that thought.
And that inability to stand that
thought says something
about a lack in Quentin's
life.
If he had had that experience,
he wouldn't
have hated it so much.
It wouldn't have been so
unbearable for him.
And Caddy completely
understands that.
So that's the background for
that repeated phrase, "Poor
Quentin."
And so this is the point
where Benjy and Quentin
are really as one.
The two brothers are as one.
And now we begin to move away
from that point of unity
between Benjy and Quentin.
Because we also know that in
fact, Caddy is a very fleeting
presence in the Quentin
section.
The person who's there
a lot is actually the
little Italian girl.
So there's a very odd choice on
Faulkner's part--that for a
good part of the Quentin
section, Quentin is actually
walking around with the
little Italian girl
that he calls sister.
So we're starting to get the
different permutations of the
word sister in this very
complex, semantic field.
"Hello, sister'...
She extended her fist. It
uncurled upon a nickel, moist
and dirty, moist dirt ridged
into her flesh...
I handed [the buns] to
the little girl.
Her fingers closed about them,
damp and hot, like worms...
I went on.
Then I looked back.
She was behind me, under my
elbow sort of, eating.
We went on.
It was quiet, hardly anyone
about getting the odor of
honeysuckle all mixed.
She would have told me not to
let me sit there on the steps
hearing her door twilight
slamming hearing Benjy still
crying Supper she would have
to come down then getting
honeysuckle all mixed
up in it."
So here we started to get the
conflation of the two sisters.
So in the italics, he's
going back to that
traumatic moment, still.
Caddy not been able to
wash herself clean.
Benjy bellowing,
doors slamming.
Caddy's still up in her room.
So still that moment.
But that moment is
bleeding into--
that moment from the past, is
bleeding into Quentin's
current walk with the
little Italian girl.
And that accounts for the images
of dirt and filth that
are being projected onto the
little Italian girl.
She's just a little
girl, eating buns.
But the images of her
are actually of
a much older woman.
Moisture and dirt ridged
into her flesh.
So at the very least, we can say
that Quentin's experience
of the entire world is channeled
through, mediated
by, and contaminated by, his
sense of the loss of sexual
innocence on the
part of Caddy.
So that every single woman that
he's going to encounter
is going to carry some
attributes of the Caddy who's
lost her sexual innocence.
And the word sister also carries
the weight of that
contamination.
But there are other interesting
permutations of
the word sister.
And I just want to take us back
now to the very opening
of the Quentin section.
And this is something that is
once again, very peculiar, a
kind of logical association not
entirely clarified for us.
"I don't suppose anybody ever
deliberately listen to a watch
or a clock.
You don't have to.
You can be oblivious to the
sound for a long while, then
in a second of ticking it can
create in the mind unbroken
the long diminishing parade
of time you didn't hear.
Like Father said down the long
and lonely light rays you
might see Jesus walking, like.
And the good Saint Francis that
said Little Sister Death,
that never had a sister."
It's making no sense to us on
page 76, and it's probably
still not making a whole lot
of sense to you right now.
We know though, that the watch
is very important.
And he steps on the watch and
breaks the face of the watch.
So he seems to have some quarrel
with that watch.
And we'll come back to this in
plenty detail at the end of
the Quentin section.
What is it?
Why is it that he's so
angry at the watch?
But for now, let's think
about that last line.
"And the good Saint Francis
that said, Little Sister
Death, that never
had a sister."
So we're just seeing the mapping
of the word sister on
to the little Italian girl.
And now the word sister is
mapped on to death, ok?
So what is it that enables that
mapping to take place?
And here, I should say something
about the way of
reading Faulkner on the whole.
I don't really think that we
need to do a lot of research
to understand Faulkner.
He's hard to understand.
But actually, it takes more
reading than doing a lot of
outside research.
But here is one moment when
actually, some outside
research would cast light
on this particular logic
association.
So I just want to bring up this
very strange possible
reference for Faulkner.
And that is, it has to do with
Saint Francis and he's telling
us that Saint Frances
is important to
him for some reason.
This is Saint Francis, Canticle
of the Sun, which
turns out to be pivoted
on the word sister.
Praised be my Lord for Sister
Moon, and for the stars...
Water, who is very serviceable
unto us, and humble and
precious and clean...
Praised be my Lord for our
Sister the death of the body,
from whom no man living
can escape.
So at the very least, we can
say that those different
mappings that we've seeing in
Quentin seem to bear a very
close correspondence to this
particular logic of
association that we see
in Saint Francis.
Obviously, even though the two
logics are similar, it's for
different reasons that Quentin
would have that kind of
clustering of terms.
So let's move on now
to see what sister
water means for Quentin.
And this is once again
going back to Caddy.
But suddenly water is
coming into play in
his relation to Caddy.
"Got to marry somebody Have
there been very many Caddy I
don't know too many will you
look after Benjy and Father
You don't know whose it is then
does he know Don't touch
me will you look after
Benjy and Father
I began to feel the water before
I came to the bridge.
The bridge was of grey stone,
lichened, dappled with slow
moisture where the
fungus crept.
Beneath it the water was clear
and still in the shadow,
whispering and clucking about
the stone in fading swirls of
spinning sky.
Caddy that I got to
marry somebody."
So the most obvious, clearest
fact is that Caddy is
pregnant, and that she needs
to marry somebody.
And she's about to
marry somebody.
So this is about the
only thing we know.
But what is interesting here is
that, when she's about to
be married and leave the Compson
house, what she says
to Quentin is, will you look
up after Benjy and father?
It is something that someone
who's about to leave will say.
Someone who's about to get
married and leave will say.
But it could also be said
by someone who is
about to kill herself.
I'm going to be gone.
There are two possible meanings
for, "Look after
Father and Benjy." Someone who's
no longer going to be
around anymore.
It's by someone who's not
going to be around.
And there are two different ways
in which Caddy could be
not around anymore.
Right now, she's going to
do the marriage option.
That's the way in which
she's not going
to be around anymore.
But in Quentin's mind, there's
already that alternative root
that he's toying with.
It would be very nice if Caddy
were to kill herself, by
drowning herself.
It would be one way.
The water this time is not
something in the bathroom.
It would be this gigantic
body of water.
But she would indeed wash
herself clean in
that body of water.
So this is one way in which
sister and water consititute a
potential mapping in
Quentin's mind.
But Caddy is not
going to do it.
She's just going
to get married.
She's going to be alive.
So this is the problem for
Quentin, is that Caddy is not
going to clean herself by
killing herself and by jumping
into the water.
And he's furious.
And the world is not--
nothing is right when she
refuses to clean herself as he
demands her to be clean.
So this is his conversation
with his father.
"And father said it's
because you are a
virgin: don't you see?
Women are never virgins.
Purity is a negative state and
therefore contrary to nature.
It's nature is hurting you not
Caddy and I said That's just
words and he said So
is virginity and I
said you don't know.
You can't know and
he said Yes.
On the instant when we come
to realize that tragedy is
second-hand."
So it would have been the right
kind of tragedy if Caddy
had just killed herself by
jumping into the water.
It would've been appropriate
cleansing kind of tragedy.
And instead, she's not
killing herself.
Somebody has to kill himself
in order to perform that
needed action.
And Quentin's father is
completely disapproving and,
in fact, making fun of
that whole operation.
That it's right that Caddy
shouldn't be too upset about
her pregnancy.
Women are never virgins
to begin with, never.
They're never virgins.
Interesting interpretation
of virginity.
But I think that it really is
an interesting observation.
That the person who is--
both on the part of Mr. Compson,
but also on the part
of Faulkner--
the person who ought to be most
upset by all of this is
actually not the most
upset about it.
And what happens when tragedy
becomes secondhand, becomes
vicarious tragedy.
Quentin is reacting to this
tragedy on the part of his
sister, and making it
his own tragedy.
Because in some sense, that's
really the only thing that he
can call his own.
So the problem with secondhand
tragedy is that it really is
somebody else's tragedy.
It is not Quentin's
own tragedy.
At the moment, he's been
devastated by it.
And he likes to be devastated.
He likes to be heroic, and
devastated, and to be
devastated on behalf
of his sister.
And to feel that he's the
one who's going to
make everything right.
But there's always the danger
that a secondhand tragedy will
very soon fade out, and
become a non-tragedy.
And that's why the word
temporary is such an
unbearable word for Quentin
to contemplate.
"And i temporary and he you
cannot bear to think that
someday it will no longer hurt
you like this now...
And I temporary and he it is
hard believing to thing that a
love or a sorrow is a bond
purchased without design.
And which matures willynilly
and is recalled without
warning to be replaced by
whatever issue the gods happen
to be floating at the time...
And o temporary and he was the
saddest word of all there is
nothing else in the world it's
not despair until time it's
not even time until it was."
So the tragedy isn't even
that Caddy is pregnant.
That's really nothing.
The tragedy is the fact that
Quentin is devastated now,
that wouldn't keep forever.
He's going to lose.
He won't be able to hold on
forever to that sense of
devastation.
And that is the tragedy that
he's going to fight to put an
end to claim, once and for all,
by doing what he does at
the end of the novel.
And this is where he jumps off
from, this is the bridge that
he jumps off from in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
And it just happens that it
seems there's some British
reader had gone there.
We know it's British
because of the
spelling of the word odor.
But at that bridge, there's
actually a plaque saying,
"Quentin Compson drowned in
the odour of honeysuckle.
1891-1910." So this is a very,
very good reader of Faulkner,
knowing exactly what is central
in Faulkner's mind.